[Musique]
c'était donc le second volet de ce
documentaire le célibat des prêtres le
calvaire de l'église la première partie
de ce film a déjà fait l'objet d'un
débat doc autour de cette enquête
fouillée vous venez de le voir réaliser
dans 8 pays et trois continents par Rémi
Bénichou et Éric Colomer avec ce constat
la majorité des clercs qu'ils soient
hétérosexuel ou homosexuel ne respecte
pas la discipline du célibat quelles
conséquence dès lors pour l'Église
catholique envisage-t-elle de moderniser
un tant soit peu les mœurs s'en sont
sains nous allons en débattre maintenant
sur ce plateau avec nos invités avec
vous pour commencer Jean-Marie guenois
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
rédacteur en chef au Figaro et
spécialiste des questions religieuses
votre dernier livre s'intitule jusqu'où
ira François divorcé remarié réforme du
Vatican anticapitalisme ces défis ses
ennemis ce livre a été publié chez
Jean-Claude lattes constance Colonna
César est également avec nous bienvenue
vous êtes journaliste auteur spécialiste
du Vatican est réalisatrice de
documentaires dont les diplomates du
pape que nous avons eu le plaisir de
présenter dans cette même émission vous
doit aussi se livre dans les secrets de
la diplomatie vaticale ouvrage publié
aux éditions du Seuil et puis enfin avec
nous Bernadette Sauvaget bienvenue à
vous vous êtes vous aussi journaliste
spécialiste des questions religieuses au
quotidien Libération cette fois et votre
dernier livre s'intitule lui l'affaire
Ramadan sexe et mensonges la chute du
Nikon ouvrage publié chez Fayard
Jean-Marie gaynouard c'est vrai c'est
vrai qu'en 2019 nous aurions pu assister
à une petite révolution parce que lors
du synode sur l'Amazonie et bien les
évêques de cette région ce sont
prononcés pour l'ordination des hommes
mariés c'était pour permettre à l'église
de couvrir cette immense territoire qui
effectivement l'Amazonie cette
proposition a été inscrite d'ailleurs
dans les du Synode autrement dit elles
avaient été validées par les
fonctionnaires Romains et le Pape a
décidé de ne pas donner suite il a Mumu
c'est ces mots quelques semaines plus
tard dans un avion je le cite le jour où
je me retrouverai face à Saint-Pierre je
ne veux pas être celui qui aura mis fin
au célibat des prêtres est-ce qu'il y a
pas une forme de l'acheter dans cette
déclaration du pape François comment en
tout cas faut-il interpréter cette
fameuse phrase c'est une prudence le
pape françois est un homme très
politique a visé il connaît bien
l'Église catholique sous toutes ses
latitudes et il a compris que malgré la
proposition effectivement votée aux deux
tiers de ce synode sur l'Amazonie de
pouvoir ordonner des hommes mariés à la
prêtrise
décidé de cette mesure sur la seule base
de ce synode aurait provoqué dans
l'église d'un séisme il connaît
suffisamment justement la sensibilité de
ce corps social de l'Église catholique
qui est extrêmement complexe dans chaque
pays une histoire très longue et que
cette mesure pourtant effectivement
attendu par beaucoup aurait provoqué
plus de de mal que de bien et n'aurait
pas forcément résolu le problème parce
que l'Église catholique à l'expérience
au Liban notamment ou dans d'autres pays
où les prêtres de rite oriental sont
mariés ce sont les catholiques près de
catholiques mariés cela ne résout pas
les questions de d'entrée au séminaire
cela ne résout pas forcément les
problèmes de violences sexuelles ou
autre et donc il a fait la part des
choses il a réfléchi il a beaucoup mûri
et la considérer qu'il n'était pas
l'heure encore pour l'Église catholique
de prendre cette décision ce
documentaire
révèle en réalité dans ces deux parties
d'ailleurs dans ces deux volets la
réalité de l'ampleur du phénomène de ce
non respect de cette règle du célibat
c'est surtout ça qu'on retient en
regardant d'abord ces documentaires
est-ce qu'il est dupe le pape François
est-ce que l'entourage du pape François
est dû ou est-ce qu'on met tout ça sous
le tapis alors je crois que personne
n'est dupe puisque toute façon ça
remonte depuis tellement d'années il y a
des rapports il y a des cas personnels
on paie pour élever des enfants y
compris d'évêques d'ailleurs et pas
seulement de prêtres dans certains pays
et c'est même la secrétariat d'État qui
s'en charge paraît-il donc non on n'est
pas dupe heureusement on a envie de dire
parce que ce qu'on appelle c'est tout de
même il y aurait un prêtre sur deux
qu'une respecte pas cette fameuse règle
voilà ce sont les chiffres qu'on utilise
dans ce documentaire qui sont étayés par
des études tout de même on n'est pas dit
mais c'est atroce de de considérer qu'il
y a ce double discours et que finalement
on continue à être là dedans et qui avec
même si c'est su on n'aboutit pas une
décision qui va jusqu'à abolir le
célibat des prêtres la proposition qui
avait été soumise au sida de l'Amazonie
dont on parlait à l'instant c'était une
vague expérience c'était même pas pour
toutes les régions c'était simplement
une expérience le climat était
Jean-Marie guenois serait ouvert la
porte de Pandore mais exactement il y
avait une sensibilité sur cette question
dans un moment très particulier ou en
plus un cardinal hostile mais comme
beaucoup dans l'église à cette nouveauté
à cette ouverture c'était saisi de la
parole du pape émérite benoistes pour
dire voyez le pape émérite Benoît XVI
est contre une avancée dans ce domaine
donc pour braquer et pour rendre cette
décision impossible parce que le pape
François a refusé parce qu'il a eu peur
d'un schisme et c'est sa première
responsabilité Bernadette sauvage et
puis je vous donne la parole juste après
pour qu'on comprenne bien
un rabat il peut se marier il peut avoir
des enfants un imam peut se marier peut
avoir des enfants un prêtre protestant
peut se marier peut avoir des enfants
pourquoi ce n'est pas possible alors
aujourd'hui aux yeux de l'Église
catholique romaine moi je fais moins
catégorique que mon confrère je pense
que d'abord françois est un homme de sa
génération il a 86 ans
il a grandi dans un univers où c'était
normal accepté etc alors que je crois
que depuis 20 ans c'est une question qui
est
incrustée dans le débat catholique et je
crois qu'en fait il y a une distorsion
entre grosso modo aujourd'hui les les
sondages montrent une majorité de de
croyants catholique et y compris dans le
noyau dur du catholicisme c'est-à-dire
les catholiques pratiquants qui sont
aujourd'hui favorables à l'organisation
de mariée et même FA aujourd'hui aussi à
l'ordination des femmes donc en fait
j'ai cité du pape François on donne le
sentiment de de laisser le pouvoir de
décider à son successeur ou à d'autres
je crois qu'il a pas enfin voilà
en fait François est quelque part moi je
crois franchement enfin François et
extrêmement
novateur en rupture avec ses positions
de morale sociale c'est-à-dire grosso
modo sur les questions de de politique
de social etc et c'est fondamentalement
un conservateur en ce qui concerne les
les
mœurs alors après avec
une chose fondamentale pour lui c'est ce
qu'il appelle l'écluse l'église
inclusive donc en fait une ne change
rien au socle de la de la discipline la
doctrine puisque le célibat n'est pas
ne fait pas partie du corps du dogme
catholique c'est une discipline et
d'ailleurs il le rappelle il a rappelé
très récemment dans un certain nombre
d'interviews et il dit lui-même que
cette discipline peut bouger mais que
lui il la bougera pas
quelque chose il est pas conservateur en
matière morale dans sur la question des
personnes homosexuelles donc il est
quand même très ouvert sur ces sujets-là
d'autant que on a l'impression
effectivement en voyant le documentaire
que la majorité des prêtres ou une bonne
partie des prêtres ne respectent pas ça
mais on oublie de dire que ça manque un
peu de nuance que beaucoup essaient de
vivre ça quand vous voyez un jeune
prêtre qui est ordonné prêtre il a 25
ans il a 30 ans il s'engage il donne sa
vie totalement toute sa vie y compris sa
vie sexuelle dans le célibat dans la
chasteté à l'église c'est le sens de cet
engagement donc
les gens tentent c'est un idéal pourquoi
cette idéal pour justement se donner
totalement aux autres être tout à tous
Alors on peut discuter tout ça c'est pas
le sujet tout à fait là mais ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que on est dans
une dans un domaine très difficile pour
pour d'ailleurs pour toute personne
d'ailleurs si difficile pour les
musulmans parce que là il y a pas de
discours
c'est l'interprétation des évangiles
l'Église catholique pense contrairement
aux protestants contrairement même aux
orthodoxes et ce n'était pas vrai dans
le premier millénaire ou l'Église
catholique avait aussi ses prêtres et il
y en a dans l'Église catholique
orientale il y en a donc elle est pas
contre ce que vient de dire Bernadette
c'est tout à fait juste c'est pas une
question de doctrine question de
discipline c'est à dire que il considère
qu'un prêtre marié et moins disponible
pour s'occuper des autres il y a des
problèmes souvent concrètement il y a eu
des problèmes de d'héritage dans les
paroisses d'argent c'est aussi ça ça a
pesé dans dans la décision mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que il faut se garder
peut-être faut bien voir l'effort d'une
vie ce sont des gens qui donnent leur
vie ils veulent ça parfois ils n'y
arrivent pas non ils en souffrent ils en
souffrent d'où la d'où la prudence du
pape aussi du pape François sur ce sujet
ils en souffrent et tout le monde en
souffre autour d'eux donc c'est vrai que
ces documents d'air analysent
certainement dans cette souffrance
quand il y a échec et alors c'est vrai
que malheureusement cette culture du
silence cette culture du secret c'est
cette notion d'hypocrisie de double
langage c'est quand même gravissime
s'est mise en question aujourd'hui parce
que il y a aussi une évolution sociale
on veut que les choses soient
transparentes que les gens disent la
vérité les prêtres eux-mêmes ont envie
de dire la vérité et que d'ailleurs
quand il s'adresse au pape lui-même
certains prêtres homosexuels on en
connaît tous dans les médias James
Alison notamment qui est un chercheur et
un prêtre qui travaille sur ces
questions le pape lui dit oui bien sûr
il faut dire la vérité il faut veut dire
que vous êtes en couple avec votre
compagnon mais donc individuellement les
choses avancent le pape est fait avancer
individuellement sur le plan humain de
l'accueil mais en effet il ne les fait
pas avancer ces dossiers sur le plan de
l'institution mais il y a quand même je
ne dirai pas comme Bernadette sauvager
que le pape est conservateur parce que
je pense qu'il a montré qu'il lançait
des débats au sein de l'Église sans les
mener à terme mais il l'a fait depuis le
synode sur la famille sur les questions
de l'homosexualité sur les questions du
célibat des prêtres et jusqu'à voir que
l'Église progresse un jour peut-être
avant d'aborder le problème de qui est
central qui peut être une des
conséquences peut-être la conséquence de
l'imposition de ce célibat
on laisse entendre à la fin de ce film
que un schisme
pourrait être craint autour de cette
question du célibat avec la création
d'église Cath alternative alors on a vu
cet exemple en Afrique mais il y en a
beaucoup d'autres
on peut craindre rachis sur cette
question au sein de l'Église catholique
certains se détourneraient de l'Église
catholique romaine pour se diriger vers
des églises catholiques alternatives
comme c'est le cas dans ce film alors je
crois que en nombre je crois que c'est
ce que agite les opposants un
assouplissement la discipline ça c'est
vraiment le le l'épouvantail quasiite
les opposants
voilà je crois qu'il faut revenir alors
il y aurait peut-être un certain nombre
de gens dans ce qu'on appelle le clergé
la caricature qui le débat en fait il
est essentiellement à ce niveau là de
l'Église c'est à dire au niveau des des
clercs au niveau des évêques et des
prêtres soit que
moi je trouve intéressant dans ce dans
ce débat c'est que quand même
majoritairement aujourd'hui
les croyons catholiques ils sont voilà
ils sont plutôt d'accord avec
l'ordination de mariée donc il y a un
double niveau je veux dire c'est la
super structure qui qui elle
freine son accord en même temps si vous
permettez
ils suivent ce que l'Église demande si
un jour l'église demande dit ok on peut
aller prêtre la plupart des gens seront
d'accord mais
on a un laboratoire en grande réelle en
Allemagne ça ça vient de se produire il
y a un synode donc un synode ça
rassemblement une sorte d'assemblée
générale d'État généraux de l'Église
catholique les Allemands l'ont décidé et
puis parmi les mesures votées il y a
cette question là est-ce qu'ils vont
aller au schisme la question que vous
posez je ne pense pas parce que aller au
schisme c'est d'abord se séparer de
l'Église catholique et on a ils ont
connaissant de toutes les expériences
précédentes historiques qui montrent que
les églises
thématique finalement
finissent par mourir ou devenir des
petits groupuscules donc ils ont tout
intérêt à rester à l'intérieur de
l'église catholique pour mener ce combat
parce que ce combat certes il est
théologique certes il est canonique le
droit de l'église il est surtout
culturel c'est pour ça que c'est si
nuancé et c'est difficile on est dans
une évolution globale de l'église et la
poussée de la société et le pape
effectivement il encourage en même temps
il freine il essaie de te dire tout ce
trou pour ensemble et c'est très
difficile parce que dans une évolution
culturelle on va voir un extrait du
documentaire si vous le voulez bien à
propos de la crise d'évocation et c'est
justement le pape François qui s'exprime
la plume la première chose qui
m'inquiète c'est la crise d'évocation
c'est notre prêtrice qui est en jeu
j'ai parlé de cette préoccupation voire
de cette hémorragie de vocation lors de
l'assemblée plénière de la Congrégation
pour les instituts de vie consacrées et
les sociétés de vie apostolique combien
de séminaires d'église et de monastères
seront fermés dans les prochaines années
en raison du manque de vocation dieu
seul le sait
[Applaudissements]
la crise des vocations alors ça c'est un
fait réel il y a deux fois moins de
prêtres en France qu'il y a 20 ans un
tiers de moins en Allemagne qu'il y a 20
ans et si on continue comme ça il y aura
plus de prêtres par exemple en Irlande
d'ici 20 ans ce sont les projections qui
sont faites donc cette crise d'évocation
elle est bien réelle et entendre le pape
François il y a une vraie prise de
conscience au plus haut sommet du
Vatican
est-ce que cette règle du célibat
constitue le blocage principal pour ce
problème de
manque de vocation cette crise de
vocation au sein de l'Église catholique
aujourd'hui alors je dirais que c'est
peut-être plus général que ça c'est
peut-être la crise de enfin l'obéissant
l'obéissance la discipline le pouvoir
les gens sont réfractaires y compris
dans une institution comme l'Église
catholique à avoir en haut une police
des mœurs qui leur dise comment agir y
compris dans l'Église catholique c'est
vrai je crois donc il y a des la société
et l'église de communiquent évidemment
on a vu après le hashtag me too le
hashtag non-stu apparaître ça c'est sur
les abus au sein des ordres religieux
mais c'est aussi vrai sur la liberté de
conscience de de mener sa vie donc avoir
une église catholique qui dit comment
doivent vivre se comporter
dans leur sexualité y compris dans des
actes très intimes d'ailleurs c'est vrai
pour aussi ce que dit l'église aux
catholiques sur leur comportement sexuel
sur ce qui est autorisé interdit etc là
aussi depuis l'encyclique de Paul VI
c'est vieux de 1968 ou sur la
contraception
l'interdiction du recourir à des
méthodes de contraceptive bien il y
avait un schisme avec les fidèles et
c'est vrai dans l'église aussi sur ces
questions de discipline donc c'est très
important si on mettait un terme à cette
règle aujourd'hui ou si on
l'assouplissait ça résoudrait en grande
partie il y a des ex problèmes de cette
crise de vocation je couvre aussi le
judaïsme le protestantisme et ils ont
l'islam ils ont les mêmes problèmes de
recrutement demandez le recrutement des
imams les pasteurs protestants parce que
il n'y a pas que la question sexuelle il
y a la question de la reconnaissance
sociale de la carrière entre guillemets
donner toute sa vie quasiment c'est pas
des journées de 8h c'est des journées de
12-15 heures c'est des weekends prix
avec une famille c'est pas facile donc
ce problème du clair qui soit quelque
soit sa religion de de
la vocation à ce type de vie de l'appel
est très très difficile maintenant je
pense pas que la question du célibat
soit un frein évidemment elle est une
grosse difficulté mais c'est pas
l'argument central quand on les voit ces
jeunes qui s'engagent chez ça aussi la
réalité quand vous les voyez ils sont
peu nombreux mais ils s'en veulent on le
voit aussi dans le domaine chez les
tradis on a aussi beaucoup donc ils y
vont maintenant je pense que le problème
il est global c'est comment la société
perçoit reconnaît ceux qui se mettent au
service quel que soit leur religion
alors les alternatives pour résoudre
cette crise d'évocation elles existent
elles sont même sur la table là un
formuler par un certain nombre d'églises
nationales et même en France à
l'occasion de la dernière assemblée
générale de la Conférence des évêques de
France et bien on a
on a mis sur la table cette idée
d'ordonner des femmes comme Jack ou
encore d'expérimenter l'ordination
d'hommes mariés aucune de ses
propositions d'ailleurs n'a été
réellement retenue au final ces
alternatives possibles que peut-on en
dire est-ce que l'Église catholique
essaye de mettre en oeuvre des mesures
pour trouver une solution à cette crise
d'évocation notamment en modifiant le
rôle des femmes au sein de l'Église
catholique je crois que là pour le coup
effectivement le débat est en cours il y
a des cardinaux influents qui ont
eux-mêmes prépositions en pensant au
cardinal archevêque de Luxembourg
Jean-Claude riche et une personnalité
montante au sein du catholisme européen
qui a fait cette prise de position dans
la croix dans le quotidien catholique la
croix il y a quelques il y a quelques
mois donc
voilà on va faire un peu l'histoire à
une certaine époque le quartier celui
qui fut Benoît XV dans sa première
époque quand il était théologien dit
progressiste
était sur une ligne favorable donc en
fait le débat il est il est il est
présent alors moi ce que je crois c'est
que de toute façon il y a un principe de
réalité qui va se poser c'est à dire que
on est à l'horizon de 10 ans mais c'est
pas simplement en Irlande à l'horizon 10
ans aujourd'hui
l'Église catholique en France à part de
vouloir combler en faisant venir des
prêtres étrangers va être dans une
situation absolument catastrophique donc
il y a une solution d'urgence à qui
pourrait être mise en place et c'était
donc la solution qui était préconisée
pendant le synode de sur l'Amazonie
c'était d'ordonner des diacres des des
gens qui sont déjà des hommes mariés
diacres qui déjà
ont plusieurs fonctions 20 dollars des
paroisses au sein de l'Église donc en
fait je crois qu'il y a une situation
d'urgence et la situation d'urgence
parce que le système qui repose beaucoup
sur les prêtres et est au bord de
l'effondrement on n'est pas
effectivement encore une fois dans une
question dogmatique une question de
disciplines ça veut dire de DRH quoi
ressources humaines ils ont pensé que
c'était mieux comme ça
elle existe n'est pas opposée sur le
fond c'est dit ou célibat ou non célibat
pour le prêtre c'est vraiment pas la
question
simplement effectivement il y a des
réserves dans les pays occidentaux de
diacres permanent donc des hommes mariés
qui pourraient peut-être servir
davantage
mais on parle aussi de d'intégrer
davantage de laïc dans les ça se fait en
fait ça se fait de la place des femmes
quid de la place des femmes
on touche une chose dont on n'a pas
parlé qui est au cœur aussi de du métier
de prêtres c'est l'acte sacré le prêtre
président il consacre le charisme et ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle les ordres sacrés
c'est le sacrement dans le mystère de
l'Église et ça effectivement il y a des
requis des prérequis tout le monde ne
peut pas le faire comme d'ailleurs dans
d'autres religions il y a un accès aux
mystère c'est vrai aussi dans la région
juive voilà et ça
la solution n'est pas forcément une
solution quantitative ou solution de
type de ressources humaines quand il
s'agit de ces questions-là et
aujourd'hui qui a la réponse on l'a pas
à Rome on l'a pas voyez-vous on est
vraiment dans une dans une on entre dans
une crise profonde Bernadette sauvageait
la très bien des grilles dans les 10 ans
et 15 ans qui viennent les paroisses de
France seront seront non pas désertées
par les fidèles il y aura moins mais il
y aura très peu de prêtres autrement dit
l'Église catholique est peut-être en
train de scier la branche sur laquelle
elle est assise parce que si dans 10 20
ans il y a plus de près pour officier
l'évangile de l'utilisation le reste ne
peut pas fonctionner faute de personnel
[Musique]
encore une fois il y a eu ces petites
phrases du pape qui suis-je pour juger
si quelqu'un est gay et de bonne volonté
qui cherche le Seigneur Qui suis-je moi
le pas pour juger et puis tout le monde
y a cru au moment du synode sur la
famille aussi des emballage d'ouverture
et rien derrière moi franchement j'étais
un peu catastrophe fait que le livre de
Frédéric Martel Sodoma qui montre quand
même l'ampleur même s'il y a une
exagération peut-être en tous les cas
l'ampleur du problème et de cette double
ce double discours ne débouche pas sur
la fin de l'ambiguïté est-ce que c'est
permis autorisé interdit on reste
toujours on sait que ça existe pour
l'instant ça existe bonjour
officiellement interdit même si on
accepte mieux les personnes
homosexuelles ça c'est vrai mais
discipline
des prêtres qui seraient homosexuels
aujourd'hui dans l'Église catholique
c'est la moindre chose peut-être
sous ce pontificat il y a moins cette
obsession des questions de d'aller
chercher le mal désigner le mal cette
culture du péché on est moins là-dedans
la théologie morale les grandes phrases
de Jean-Paul II le tout ça c'était voilà
ça a disparu du vocabulaire du pape à
mon avis Bernadette sauver sur cette
hypocrisie appelons cela comme ça aussi
concernant l'homosexualité au sein de
cette église catholique qu'est-ce que
c'est une question de crédibilité donc
je crois qu'effectivement il y a une
exigence aujourd'hui il faut que le
messager soit en accord avec son message
ça a été tout toute la le reformatage de
la papauté qui a fait café le pape
François une papauté modeste parce que
conforme aux valeurs évangéliques c'est
vraiment c'est ça il y a cette question
de la crédibilité de de l'Église
catholique et effectivement je veux dire
je crois que chacun d'entre nous ont
un petit peu l'église de l'intérieur on
sait effectivement qu'il est
pas important du clergé qui qui est
homosexuel aujourd'hui
il y a effectivement une ouverture
pastorale qu'on dit du Père François
voilà qui qui revient de cette notion de
l'église inclusive mais il a c'est
pareil il n'a pas touché le socle et par
exemple il y a un article du du du
catéchisme qui dit que les
actes homosexuels sont très fréquents
pervers donc un certain nombre de gens
qui rappellent quand voilà
c'est ça que ça veut dire alors le pape
François quand même accompli une
révolution sur ce sujet il a la petite
phrase la valeur dans cyclique qui
suis-je pour juger la première fois que
le pape dit ça alors pourquoi il dit ça
il ne parle pas de l'homosexualité il
parle des personnes homosexuelles c'est
quand même très différent et puis il y a
aussi la tendance au masculin il y a
beaucoup de prêtres effectivement qui
ont cette tendance sont pas forcément
des homosexuels pratiquant en quelque
sorte donc là aussi il faut faire
attention et je crois que l'Église
justement elle revient bien la société
telle qu'elle est aux États-Unis
notamment le Jésus James Martins
beaucoup ce sujet
au niveau mondial pour une pour une
reconnaissance des personnes et il n'est
pas question d'exclure des personnes
parce qu'elles sont homosexuelles c'est
bien ça le discours d'ailleurs c'était
d'ailleurs le discours avant des moins
connu mais c'est une constante la notion
d'homosexualité c'est autre chose que ça
touche des questions anthropologie
reposant sur l'interprétation de la
Bible on va pas entrer dans ce débat et
c'est aussi une partie du sujet mais moi
je trouve que il s'est passé quelque
chose pendant ces années sur ce sujet là
il est pas fermé il est quand même
question ouverte et le pape François a
beaucoup apporté là-dessus maintenant il
y a beaucoup de résistance et il
faudrait pas que les gens moi je suis
pas d'accord de dire il y a
effectivement des personnes de tendance
homosexuelles qui sont prêtres mais
c'est comme le célibat tout à l'heure et
que ce soit au cinéma
en couple mais oui mais c'est ce qu'on
voit dans ce film il y en a évidemment
je n'irai pas ça mais
celui qui s'engage à cette villa tant à
une vie tant à donner toute sa vie et
moi je j'atteste j'en connais beaucoup
qui visent cela aussi on va on va parler
d'un sujet pour finir nous reste encore
un peu de temps mais plus beaucoup
malheureusement mais qui n'est pas
abordé dans dans ce documentaire sont
les violences sexuelles commises au sein
de l'Église catholique je vais rappeler
simplement quelques chiffres livrés par
le fameux rapport sauvé du nom de celui
qui a présidé en France la commission
indépendante sur les abus sexuels dans
l'église il a été remis en début octobre
fin octobre pardon début octobre 2021 il
conclut que l'institution ecclésiastique
et le milieu le plus propice aux
violences sexuelles après le cadre
familial 216
000 victimes ont été répertoriés depuis
1950 330 000 si on y ajoute les abus
sexuels venus du personnel laïque qui
participe à certaines institutions
catholiques puis 80% des victimes
sont des jeunes garçons et donc là on
est évidemment sur la question de la
pédocrinalité est-ce que il y a une
corrélation entre l'imposition du
célibat au prêtre et les violences
sexuelles auxquelles on assiste dans
l'église et on a assisté dans l'Église
catholique
moi je suis de celle qui pense que la
frustration sexuelle ne crée pas le
pédocrinel je pense qu'ils ont c'est
très difficile de ça me paraît ça me
paraît évident enfin je veux dire
la pédophilie
c'est quelque chose de très spécifique
enfin je veux dire il frustration
sexuelle on l'a comble autrement que
qu'avec des actes sexuels avec des
enfants voilà en plus on sait
effectivement que le milieu où se
produisent les violences sexuelles
contre les enfants c'est le milieu
familial donc les pères de famille les
oncles voilà les frères donc
je crois qu'il faut se garder de ça en
revanche en revanche ce discours sur la
sexualité aussi avoir une emprise
spirituelle de par son statut sur le
discours sur la sexualité
je pense que ça va bouger enfin c'est en
train de bouger c'est aussi libre sur la
sexualité
fait que il y a eu une confusion je veux
dire jusqu'à une époque très récente en
fait on mettait quasiment sur le même
plan un prêtre qui avait une relation
avec une femme et un prêtre qui se
livrait à des actes de violence sexuelle
sur les enfants c'est ça plutôt c'est
c'est la confusion
sur un discours le discours confusant ou
confusion c'est pas qu'on peut dire sur
la sexualité
oui l'agresseur faut distinguer
l'agresseur violent de celui qui tombe
amoureux d'une femme c'est quand même
des choses très très différentes et
c'est le risque de cette problématique
c'est à dire que effectivement il y a
des cas d'agression sexuelle sur des
religieuses par exemple c'est très
documenté en Afrique et dans d'autres
pays et c'est un dossier qui est en
train de sortir
bon il y a c'est terrible affaire de
pédocriminalité on y revient pas
maintenant est-ce que tout cela est lié
à la frustration je crois que je
l'accorde avec ma ma console de
libération
effectivement non regardez les chiffres
dans les familles dans les milieux
sportifs il y a eu pas mal d'enquêtes
sur le sujet également les milieux de
l'éducation on a les mêmes pathologies
en quelque sorte des gens qui ont une
vie apparemment normale et puis qui qui
agresse qui sont qui sont vraiment des
agresseurs alors il nous reste une
minute
quoi c'est à dire ce que montrer le
rapport sauvé c'est que
beaucoup d'agresseurs beaucoup de
d'abuseurs beaucoup de prédateurs de
l'Église catholique ils choisissait de
faire carrière essentiellement dans
l'enseignement dans l'enseignement dans
les milieux de jeunes voyez c'est là où
il y a des jeunes là où il y a des
enfants et pédocrinels
et la pédophilie la pédophriminalité
mais je me dis il y a quand même aussi
une pour un problème de sexophobie
peut-être dans la formation des prêtres
dans des séminaires qui est l'appareil
malheureusement aussi sur lequel se base
la position la doctrine la morale
sexuelle de l'Église qui est peut-être à
revisiter c'est le domaine où finalement
l'Église a le moins changé si on regarde
des grands les grandes avancées sur le
cuménisme sur la doctrine sociale
justement en matière de morale sexuel de
morale familiale de discipliner que elle
refuse de regarder je pense que ça nuit
à la maturité peut-être des gens dans
les séminaires qui devraient
s'interroger plus sur ces questions
et les agresseurs puisque c'est comme ça
que vous les avez nommés représenterait
selon ce fameux rapport sauvé environ
2,5% de la totalité des prêtres
autrement dit
attention à ne pas généraliser sans
doute pour rejoindre ce que vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure Bernadette
sauvageet un grand merci vraiment à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à cette
émission des Badoc après le second volet
de ce documentaire célibat des prêtres
le calvaire de l'église vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
bien entendu merci aussi à sel massali
qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission prochain débat
doc ça sera bien sûr avec ce
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]